did you know Easter is completely ripped
off from the pagan holiday ostara
only a matter of time before he finds
out what Easter is really about
[Music]
the libs hate everything good
including Easter apparently probably
including Easter especially so we will
delve the depths of the anti-easter
propaganda percolating on Tick Tock this
video is brought To Us by Hala very
fitting bring out the anti-easter
Brigade did you know Easter is
completely ripped off from the pagan
holiday
here we go here we go you're gonna
you're gonna start me off like this oh
here we go again this is with the libs
they always love to say they say do you
know that every Christian thing that we
like is actually Pagan and unfortunately
there are many Christians who have
bought into this propaganda and it's not
true it's not true when it comes to
Christmas it's not true when it comes to
Easter it's not true when it comes to
any of the other days but let's hear her
argument you know we celebrated the
goddess today I'm sorry if I didn't
pronounce it correctly she's a goddess
of fertility spring and rebirth the
symbol for fertility has always been an
egg forever and her spirit animal is a
rabbit so this is where the Easter egg
and the Easter Bunny comes from that
can't be real right except when
Christians adopted the egg as their
Easter symbol in the 13th century they
used to paint it red which symbolizes
Jesus's blood so nobody really knows
when Jesus was resurrected but
Christians decided it would be on a
pagan holiday the people they
slaughtered for being Pagan there is no
evidence that this was a pagan goddess
really at all with one exception the 8th
Century Catholic monk Saint bead the
some reference to this Pagan goddess but
in this sole reference to this Pagan
goddess there is absolutely no mention
that the symbol of this goddess was a
bunny that's just completely made up and
then she says well the reason that
Christians celebrate Easter when they
celebrate Easter is because they ripped
off this holiday supposed holiday that
celebrated the supposed Pagan goddess
but that isn't true one we don't have
really any textual evidence of any
Festival celebrating this this Pagan
goddess but two we know the reason that
Christians celebrate Easter at Easter is
because it's after the Passover because
the last supper was a Passover seder and
then Christ went through his passion and
was crucified and was resurrected very
simple it's right there in the book If
this woman had taken even two seconds to
read the book she she would have not
fallen into this misinformation you know
we just went through the Easter season
and I realized something
I worship a brown-skinned man
as God put a pause there
what is your evidence that our Lord has
brown skin I'm not saying he doesn't
have brown skin but this is modern
liberals like to say this see Jesus was
black
foreign
[Music]
or something like that there's no
evidence of that at all Jesus is a Jew
and I strongly suspect he looks like
Jews all right fair enough and I
actually strongly suspect he looks like
the face that we see on the Shroud of
Turin why are they so obsessed with that
they're so obsessed with that because
they have to it has nothing to do with
Christianity they just have to push this
liberal political agenda According to
which white people are evil and
non-white people are the only good
people he was hung on a tree
that's the way the Bible describes it
nailed to the cross he was hung on a
tree
so he was essentially lynched no he
wasn't lynched this is a really
important distinction Christ was tried
and
executed by the Civil Authority a
lynching is a vigilante killing the
passion and crucifixion of Our Lord was
legal and he submitted himself to that
and this has important implications for
the way Christians ought to view the
Civil Authority and ought to view
political Life by Caucasian people who
were in control of the holy land at that
time put a pause there Christ was handed
over to his execution by Jews I'm not
knocking the Jews here our Lord is a Jew
as well but notice what he says he says
Jesus is a brown-skinned man and he was
killed by Caucasian people I was the
same people he was he was turned over to
his death by his own people they knew
him not this is all attested to in the
gospels but the story does not support
the liberal political project and so
this lib when he has to choose between
liberalism and Christianity yet he
chooses liberalism and he chooses to
rewrite Christianity to fit his own
narrative so I worship a lynched
brown-skinned man
who was killed by people with white
privilege
and I celebrate his resurrection
and his effect on my life
you might worship all of those things
but I would recommend you worship our
Lord that might Define your religion but
I would recommend you check out the
religion of Christianity because it's
it's a lot better in a society Rife with
anti-religious ideology like the views
that we hear on a daily basis and we're
hearing right now actually it can be
incredibly challenging to ground oneself
in what we know to be true and good
choose today to embrace your faith and
start building a habit of prayer join me
in thousands of others on hallow the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States aloe is helping all of us
to maintain a prayer routine daily it
can help you too download the app for
free at hello.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way not sure
where to start check out my favorite
podcast father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year available on the Hallow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg and
Jonathan roomie who portrays Jesus in
The Chosen with hello you can customize
a personal prayer plan that works for
you listen wherever you are with
downloadable offline sessions download
hello.com Knowles get an exclusive three
months free that is three months
absolutely free at hallow.com
Knowles can we talk about the dark
history of Easter let's talk about it
sorry to say the Easter
east of any aspects of traditional
Christianity holidays practices
doctrines the bunnies the eggs
Springtime came not from Christ or the
Bible became from Pagan religion Easter
Sunday is a Babylonian pagan holiday
which idolizes the fertility goddess
Ishtar worshiping Ishtar this is what
they always do because it's all made up
they they don't know which Pagan Idol
they should refer to or which Pagan
feast day they should refer to
so they'll say Christmas is really the
Pagan feast day of saturnalia Christmas
is really the pagan holiday of Soul
Invictus Christmas is really the pagan
holiday of mithras but the only thing it
can never be is Christmas women will
require to celebrate the conception by
laying down at the Temple of ishar and
having relations with anybody who walks
in there is a very very dark history on
why they color eggs babies respect
supervised and the blood of the infants
were dipped in the eggs for Ishtar no
none of this had to do with Christianity
the bunnies and the eggs are not as
simple as they seem and this holiday is
not holy y'all be safe so it is Holy it
marks the resurrection of of Christ
Ishtar who is who is a better attested
to a pagan goddess does not have a bunny
for her representation and the bunny
it's actually a product of German
lutherans and it seems relatively
harmless to me it doesn't I've attended
Easter celebrations for my whole life
we've never sacrificed any babies modern
liberalism sacrifices 800 000 babies a
year and and they don't want to
acknowledge that but no Easter
celebrations don't do that Easter is not
a secular holiday and apparently there
are people out there who try to
pushially encourage certain families who
do not celebrate that to celebrate it
various people from various religions
don't believe in your religion and in
your religious holidays and in your
celebrations I don't celebrate
Easter we've got a badass over here I
was baptized Catholic as a baby mostly
because you know the infants can go to
not heaven if they die and they're not
baptized and for some reason my grandma
was like ah about that my terrible
parents didn't want me to perish and
burn in hell forever I hate them I hate
you Dad that's what all liberalism is
it's just I hate you dad keep going a
lot of holidays that we celebrate here
that are seemingly secular
do not have a basis in secular holiday
business
Easter is not a secular holiday
I keep waiting for this to end because
she just keeps repeating the same phrase
says Easter is not a secular holiday
[Music]
right
it's a holiday that that marks the
resurrection of our Lord Jesus Christ so
you're right that's not a secular
holiday there's really no such thing as
a secular holiday because holiday refers
to holy days now Easter is celebrated in
America we have all sorts of federal
holidays that are Christian holidays
what the libs want to do is replace all
of the real holidays with fake holidays
so they they want to get rid of
Christmas and Easter and the public
celebration of these things so the
question for us is do you want the good
old real holidays that refer to real
religion or do you want the Bizarro
pseudo-holidays like trans visibility
day of the leftist anti-religion happy
Easter everybody
[Music]